what we are going to do is be ambitious
in our negotiations to negotiate the
best deal for the British people and
that will include the maximum possible
access to the European market for firms
to trade with and operate within the
European market
Prime Minister Theresa made that UK
prime minister of course addressing
Parliament a little earlier today may
giving the battered pound some needed
relief after she agreed that lawmakers
should be allowed to say on her plan for
taking Britain out of the European Union
for moral maze latest remark that's
bringing up Rex the editor Sally Kennedy
hmm so overnight we were led to believe
the Parliament would get a vote and then
she sort of stepped back from it saying
yes we'll debate it but she didn't
categorically say whether
parliamentarians would have a vote
ideally ideally trees may well avoid
their vote but it's very little she can
do to actually do that there's a good
good evidence that she will maybe a
allow a vote and not feel particularly
bound by it in the end have have a
little sip of water before I get you
that next question it's very emotional
about it's tricky isn't it because she
has to give Parliament something the
House of Commons something because the
majority is so slim and in fact in the
House of Lords there isn't one is there
and she's hoping not to have given
something this is a bit of a u-turn in
the last 24 hours
she read the Sunday newspapers people
like Nick Clegg former Deputy Prime
Minister ed Miliband
former Labour leader other people within
her party was starting to say well you
hold on you've spent a week of the
Conservative Party conference laying out
various red lines or your party's laid
out various red lines these negotiations
you're not going to give us a say and
they had hoped that the the leadership
had hoped that they'd be able to resist
that and obviously in the last 24 hours
they've decided to give a stop to
Parliament today case Tamara the new
spokesman for brexit didn't the
opposition Labour Party pointing out to
say that the British people voted for
brexit he's not seeking to block that
but what they didn't vote for is the
terms the the mandate didn't give her a
mandate to her to negotiate her way out
and we're probably gonna see a lot of
parliamentary our language and the like
for there it's unlikely to actually stop
right so yeah Simon I have to quote
David bloom
HSBC you said a note last week sterling
is now the de facto our position the de
facto official opposition to the
government's policies because it's you
know not quite clear that there is a
working opposition so what will
Parliament decide to do if Parliament
does indeed get a vote on anything
substantial well it's less what it will
do with the vote it's more whether how
binding that vote would be one thing is
very clear is tourism a is not not going
to give Parliament any say in in whether
article 50 of the Lisbon treaty should
or should not be triggered that's the
the mechanism by which we start the the
talks and at the moment trading may
holding fast to her feeling that she has
the right to start those talks and
nobody else although tomorrow we start
seeing a a legal challenge to that to
start to run through the British Court
yeah what is the hope for that legal
challenge having any impact Simon it can
throw sand in the wheels as basically
they won't what it can do is if a judge
refuses to side with may then it was an
issue that goes to the House of Commons
House of Lords and this could make a
more protracted debate even more
protracted and so the people are going
to be looking very closely at that
although a new mirror pointing out this
afternoon in a report to clients that
people shouldn't put too much stock in
it they shouldn't be necessarily a surge
in the pound if if the court does side
with a with the people who are trying to
get made to it to give Parliament a more
of a say it's very much an issue though
that it could throw sand in the wheels
and there's weed today as we saw today
sand in the wheels can send the pants or
yeah